what do the wrong [ __ ] oh there they go
we're here today at Hollywood Sports
Park the premier paintball and airsoft
park in Southern California if you guys
want to play and you're in the area come
on down
tell me corridor digital sunshine we're
here today to play fpv top-down
simulator this is so crazy as soon as I
got in these goggles I just had to stand
there for 30 seconds and consider what
the hell was going on I heard there was
evil criminal named Marv Michael who got
a hold of a time-traveling device he
plans on going back and changing history
I'm here to stop it
convicts in this ring
Oh God ha Good Conduct
okay a little people well there's
another one yeah oh god it's a hipster
thank God you know how they can get they
can ruin everything I don't see him
anywhere
Texas distributing my flower you evil
warlords have been around for a thousand
years it's time to end it well
those I blame oh yeah whoa
now I can only get through this doorway
victories look whoa
Michael I'm sure I'll see you again
I think the first games any went pretty
well those henchmen are not stuff does
everyone make them out to be but Mar
Michael got a couple good shots in
fortunately the reign of terror is over
I just got word that they placed a
couple bombs throughout the city be able
to take care of that I'm going to have
three minutes to disarm three bombs I
have to go to each one and have about
four times if I'm unable to disarm them
this is going to get a lot worse is my
worst fear right now is hitting a wall I
literally have no idea where these bombs
are
is that that one right there oh [ __ ]
anyone okay Bob I'm on my mother
oh is that an R Michael who is that
gotta hurry
okay here's knowing you're gonna here's
another one baby this is so disorienting
where's the other one where's the other
bone
Oh No Oh No thank you even back okay
okay where's your the wrong [ __ ]
Oh exactly is that it in the middle is
that it then in the real
[Music]
did I get too cocky I think after I won
the first round I thought maybe that
things would get easier and it's heavily
guarded did everything I could and
sometimes you just get beat am I going
to win next time
bet your ass for the third and final
game we're gonna be doing something
super cool it's going to be hostage
rescue with president red yeah so he's
basically going to try to defend me I'm
gonna have to get him from one side of
the map to the other then we won't be
safe until we get all the way to the
container on the other side of the map
he can't move without me and I can't see
without him
he is my eyes Ally I'm his shield Ruben
are you ready mr. president I'm ready
sir all right way to countenance I have
president ray visit stay close
I'm close I won't let these escaped
convicts time traveling nice kick you he
traveled time they did one in a previous
lifetime Oh God
that guy's great then it'll be alarmed
ahead the President shall feel our
moving keep moving keep moving mr.
Boogedy right he's moving a second date
today
yeah I know hey go that's all you look
silly yeah we got more come and go in
the building go darling all right we got
a moment see either quick
don't you the window mr. president go
through the window I'm going no not be
well more I'll get you you escaped
Congress meant world we're into play
watch me Wow and soldier down okay with
the president yeah he took care of them
cover me I love it if they look okay I
got 500 men all right the car down there
might be a lot of park bogum oh that was
so pretty pretty okay oh yeah I'm flying
me come on Oh hot you're hot right there
right there I want to hit in the head
behind you oh yeah I hear you I hear you
whoa whoa whoa whoa you're healed
morning mr. president there's a birthday
we are closer because it's going
building is the president can't take
careful he's right there thank you is
that all you got this is Meg this was
this follow me stay close those bad guys
everywhere boy I'm a busy one
oh man oh okay there they go because mr.
president mr. president I'm letting out
with the bras of it okay yeah I'm
looking out we're going to get to there
you got this
no dad oh we got a jar Michael all right
one more time
is that their president
I got real dark kind of she find the
time forever man you were so fun
[Music]